how scum races PIPA today we're gonna
Fabul eyes some beautiful people into
being families so I dasn't Twitter who
need to finalize everyone is like me me
me me me yeah well not everything is
about you
alright you're not fine you know it's
fine you wanted me to fight with you
I'll do it let's finalize this Swedish
girl please don't sue me you can't sue
people from Sweden that's like our
superpower
see already we're seeing significant
improvements on this poor poor Swedish
lady who probably wishes that she didn't
treat me right oh my god that looks
awful awfully beautiful sorry sorry okay
now she needs to somehow become fabulous
that looks so good that looks [ __ ]
amazing why does he look so disturbing
let's add some wrinkles for realism
let's add some Kaua'i effect
and it's done it's [ __ ] done before
after
alright next on the list of selfish
people we have Jules my god that looks
so good oh my god I should be charging
for making these let's not forget about
those eyebrows oh my god this turned out
great
what if her glasses were lips I asked
myself that never I never yeah
GM it what just happened the nightmares
they never read like I don't want to say
it but I think we can all agree on she
looks like a vagina face don't flag this
video and let's not forget it it too
much - for good luck beautiful sorry I'm
so sorry Jules
but it wasn't my fault we have Katie I
like what Katie is doing here I don't
know Katie if you ever ask yourself if
you wanted to be a giraffe because your
dream is about to come true don't even
worry about it you look so great I am a
horrible person we're doing this to my
fence a caption for this picture when
your friends who try to take a picture
and you're not ready okay next up
Benedict Cumberbatch
what if Cumberbatch was a named have we
ever asked us this question before you
look cute just like that
sake ah there's that catchy
million-dollar smile okay I don't know
what happened with the aunt idea but I
mean this is equally as good right [ __ ]
alderman tennis I don't know what you
want from me okay think he's an egg now
there you go Benedict aunt fangirls will
still probably make out with him let's
be honest here
all right we're back I took them all
break so we fab you light some fans but
I think it's time we move on to some
just straight-up
weird pictures so a popular trend seems
to be to put arms on birds it already
looks really good
kawaii as [ __ ] plus I don't even have to
put that much effort I mean I'm turned
on let's try a different pose it's very
natural that's some real kinky [ __ ] ok I
got this weird idea it probably won't
work ok that's a kangaroo with no arms
but wait it gets better
it's never gonna work I wanted his arms
to be sharks cuz that's badass
maybe it's shark boobs yes shark boobs I
just came up with that genius you're
welcome Internet know there's shark
hands I'm kidding you thought you've
seen it on didn't ya it looks a bit too
innocent to have sharks on these [ __ ]
hands let's make them look more evil
done oh my god looks hundred percent
real and authentic right I am clearly I
clearly need to stop doing what the hell
I'm doing I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did go ahead and hit that
like button and I will see you in the
next one that's always thank your
watching stay awesome bright blue key
so speed yet
thousand